well it's the most repeated line that
you have said back to you from one of
your movies I think you know no mercy or
sweep the leg
from The Karate Kid movies and I think
you know that from rang true for so many
people you know over three generations
so they remember all those lines and and
Rambo they remember all the action and
hearing in in England Cagney and Lacey
was so popular so they remember you know
the buffoon
you know victors Becky those three
particular ones obviously you've done
many many more besides that those three
really big ones which one is your
personal favorite my president of those
to me well I guess the amount of time
you spent six years on the series and
you have such a good time no one knew
what we had you know and in reference to
Cagney and Lacey you know but no one
knew what we had in reference to Karate
Kid and we just did it for me was just
another heavy and I had a break from
Cagney and Lacey and we did it and until
it became this icon 25 years later and
510 I guess really three generations
have adhere to it and I'm so active in
an anti-bullying campaign in America
because John Crees was the ultimate
pulley but you never realized all of
that while shooting that movie and I
guess Rambo was fun I think Rambo
strictly because I wanted another
commercial success while I was doing a
TV series after you know the success of
Karate Kid but my favorite really is
those one of my favorites really is
Wyatt Earp with Kevin Costner I had such
a ball I cried when I left the set
because I love doing westerns
and trying to develop some and get them
funded and all but it's an uphill battle
Western is a tough sell these days but
you know there's been so many wonderful
memories across the board in all these
years you know countless moments
you